e aí galera que este campeonato com
vocês mas o que é isso é o primeiro
vídeo de 2015 papai mas o windows ou por
que você demorou tanto para postar o
primeiro vídeo 2015 eu demorei mais com
um uma coisa minha que é é porque o que
se a gente falar no twitter como olha só
removendo a inscrição que você não
estava exposta no vídeo mostrando a cena
mostrando um dia eu fiquei por um dia
mas eu voltei para alegria da nação tá
falando de virada de ano na virada de
ano virou o ano já estão no ano 2015
quer dizer a gente ainda está em 2014
até ele cair na real que caiu em 2015 é
sempre assim começa o ano passado
janeiro fevereiro março vai fazer uma
prova na escola hoje aqui dia a dia 26
beleza 26 03 2004 ou [ __ ] é 2015 passa
cinco mês corrente no domingo tornando
2014 2015 e ska e bota 15 na rede vence
talca que é 2015 já entrando em 2016
ainda me dizer se repetisse a 2015 com
na veia 2016 já tentando me 17 e assim
sucessivamente humanidade vai ver o que
volta às aulas cheio de comprar matéria
hoje em dia o menino vão com a mãe
comprar o material é do meu tempo eu
ficava em casa esperando ansiosamente o
caderno - fez da padaria mas saí 8 horas
da manhã para comprar material é ficar
em casa pelo tomate com muito ou se
ajudar um bom tomar quando chegava em
casa com meu irmão era o que a mulher
bonita olhos verdes e os fartos cabelos
loiros jogadas ao vento pra minha irmã o
que era moranguinho caderno de foi
generosa e personalizada e pra mim era o
que cred ao rapaz saiu de dar pra correr
no molhado com uma prancha para todos e
só deus sabe apontar o que eu senti no
coração que hoje em dia nasceu menino
ficar em casa e tem que ir com a mãe
para comprar e tem que ser do bem 10
nelsinho foi ontem 10 o menino cost na
enxuta canela bate na cara e esperneou e
no chão da papelaria e até
também é isso o homem cada vez que eu
gosto daqui mexe o noise a choro até a
mãe comprar um caderno uma idéia eu
ganhar meu caderno não podia dar um pio
eu pegar no caderno o [ __ ]
como é que é ouvir e ouvir alguma coisa
falou esse caderno aí não mas não longe
de longe de mim eu falei ou [ __ ] e
rapaz bonito na capa dessa inclusive
esse rapaz aqui eu acho que quando eu
crescer quero ser bom e que dilma tinha
que aceitar a gente tem algum pai
assiste neste vídeo a multidão cadernos
em adesivos seu filho meu caderno da
moranguinho da minha mãe tinha de si io
caderno bem novamente a dizer que quero
que era loira bonita era uma aranha ex
beira mar u quando a festa passando o
jornal e minas albano mato nas pessoas
um andróide o cheiro pedra de cocaína
que manda o pé de maconha roupas alta
prende à parte o roaming na panela não
sei nada não está passando aqui e peguei
enquanto shakira vai roubar meu irmão
que me restou e não há feridos nem sobre
a licença é a lei da vida às histórias
de ano não assisti ontem 9 bateu helton
eo que foi feito nesse mundo do crime a
pena viajar como nos cadernos ligado
dentro de um ato de ver o adesivo mesmo
quem não me rebelei eu lembro como se
fosse hoje do primeiro caderno de
adesivo que eu tive na minha vida porque
cabelo que tem adesivo você queira ou
não queira é o que acham que somente
então o que acontece cria-se um certo
interesse do pessoal da saúde é o
seguinte o caderno c adesivo é assim
você abre o caderno em tese parece que
brilha na sua cara mas só chegando amigo
entre da designada êxito mas só pegar um
negócio deles é menor de idade e é aí
que você dá o veredito final pode pegar
qualquer um adesivo
- o grande porque todo cada um quer
dizer que esse prédio ele vem um melhor
desenho de stan e dois gigantes que eu
costumo dizer que existem três maiores
dúvidas da humanidade a primeira qual o
sentido da vida a segunda de um
viemos e para onde vamos e a terceira é
saber onde é que você vai aprender o
adesivo grande o seu cabelo que o
decisão difícil a gente vou falar pra
você e eu completei 20 anos agora em
janeiro e ainda a tese da 8ª série pelo
seu negócio é às vezes às vezes a dor
era tão grande que arrancava foi na
decisiva em casa e deixam pra ninguém
pedir e aí você chega na escola você
reencontra seus amigos as pessoas você
gostar e você ama todo mundo você ama
todos os seus amigos até eles contarem
com as férias deles estavam sendo melhor
que a sua que as suas férias é onde lava
louça em casa domingo facebook instagram
twitter ea série dos amigos a onda na
disney no beto carreiro world acho que
passei na nossa festa foi tão boa
eu tô tão feliz também foi tão boa não
te dizer para ela o senhor luís que bom
que se você está feliz que suas férias
foi boa que bom eu espero que você morra
de felicidade
eu quero que você morra de felicidade
álvaro e me convidou beto carrero world
eu quero que você comente aqui embaixo
que você fez nessas férias ou como está
sendo as suas férias aí você viu isso no
facebook a pedir que você volte lá no
facebook e clique em curtir como forma
de agradecimento está entretanto você
você falar no facebook apostar nesse
vídeo clique em curtir e se você está
aqui no youtube você dá um gostei beleza
e para não perder nenhum vídeo do canal
você clica em inscrever-se aqui muito
obrigado a cheia de vida até aqui para
ler